the Joe Rogan experience the other movie
you have to get you guys have to see on
the road
grizzly man you've seen that the
documentary yeah yes greatest
unintentional comedy in the history of
comedies the what could go wrong what
was the thing you showed us yesterday
bear that were through the 80s movie Oh
bear eats mushroom when he eats the
mushrooms he has a bear I hadn't seen it
but maybe have you seen them no there's
a movie about them barely two mushrooms
Jamie look up the scene on YouTube what
is this movie about it's about a oh
these are Amanita muscaria when I was
really [ __ ] terrifying yeah he's like
sees a butterfly or something and he's
tripping balls so this is a nature
documentary
oh well thanks it looks like a real bear
though so we're not sure they did I
don't think that's what the bear seen
things maybe the bears taking a nap bro
oh this is hilarious that Amanita
muscaria mushroom is a weird mushroom
that's that one that they think is
that's from the gianmarco allegro book
the sacred mushroom and the cross he
attributed that to the birth of
Christianity makes a pretty good outfit
though yes it does the Santa Claus
outfit the Pope yeah the Pope yeah
there's a lot of connections between
mushrooms and ancient Christianity it's
[ __ ] really interesting stuff holy
[ __ ] what are we watching this is what
this is this is the bare bears tripping
balls tripping balls they glued a
butterfly to him not really there oh
it's real yeah Oh God
will you ever see the Jaguar tripping
out on ayahuasca Jaguars eat the the
either they eat work they're either
eating the harmine or they're eating the
ayahuasca vine one of them one of the
two might just be the harming whatever
the reading is having some sort of a
psychedelic effect on them and the
Jaguars eat these leaves and then to
just lie on there and their pupils are
dilated and they're tripping balls like
obviously tripping balls like to see a
jaguar rolling around on the floor in
the middle of the jungle after eating
leaves
it's very strange you never seen that no
young Jamie please but I was trying find
out what that movie the bear was all
about I just thought it's for 1988 what
is it about in the whole movie I don't
that's about life of a bear I don't know
some kids maybe from Francis I mean
Allyson Wunderland sit find a Jaguar
high on DMT to trip you watch this
Jaguar eat these leaves here it goes go
fullscreen young Jamie go full screen
look at him he's tripping so this Jaguar
he seeks out these these plants eat some
and then he's just lying there like
[Music]
the thing about the people who take that
ayahuasca too is they see Jaguars it's
part of the vision one of what they're
doing is connecting to some Jaguars that
are out there tripping balls to
[Applause]